how much did you have uh at every age to
reach a million dollars in retirement
at age 25 do you know the number
3 100 bucks that's not a lot david
you're 25 yeah
3 100 bucks in a retirement account not
a lot
you know the number one thing on how to
become a millionaire what's up you just
got to get started you got to start with
3 100 bucks like of course step one if
you don't sign up
you don't got it yeah exactly all right
so that's number one by age 30
by age 30 you need to have 29 000
in your 401k account balance not bad so
my 30 year old's out there push the
thumbs up if you got that
whether that's in a 401k ira retirement
account let's see if you're gonna uh our
guy javier i'm 23 and i'm on track yeah
love that i love that you can read these
stuffs out david because i know you're
watching the comments
age 35
66 grand that's the number right there
40. i'm 40 123 thousand dollars i'm
there that's because i started when i
was
27 years old okay i got two years i'm
just kidding
i'm 28 28. okay
uh by age 45
you should have 202 thousand dollars in
your 401k if you're going to be on track
to retire a millionaire by age 50 you're
talking 314 000
by age 55 you're talking
470 thousand dollars by age 60 you
should have just shot shy of 700 000
uh in your retirement account let that
compound interest do what it do and if i
got 60 year olds out there watching the
show respect to you let us know if
you're there
a couple quick comments ross olson i'm
33 i got 110 well done
birth of cool
i'm negative 90k yeah that's the
direction we need to be that's probably
student loan debt i'm assuming let's get
that done
um
either way just quick disclaimer these
numbers are based on receiving the
median salary which is about fifty
thousand dollars in this country right
now contributing a meeting and
percentage that's six percent of your
salary every year about three grand and
receiving a fifty cent match up the
dollar a little quick disclaimer but the
point is this
at least you know where you need to be
based on a certain age if you're there
awesome keep crushing it if you're not
now you've got some benchmarks or some
milestones that you need to hit and
newsflash you can do this
you can do it
okay just get started start contributing
understanding starts sucking away six
percent ten percent whatever your number
is put that in retirement account retire
a millionaire contribute more step it up
look at the man in the mirror boom next
thing you know you're a millionaire yeah
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken